[Music]
[Music]
chris
are you minute taking because sarah's
not with us today yes
yes thanks um so we're now on
youtube so you'll meet your mics until
the meetings
properly started please
once we have confirmation comms
b
yeah chair we're um we've received
confirmation from comms that we're
ready to start um it's almost 10 o'clock
now so if you want if you would like to
start the meeting
okay i will do um
[Music]
we were expecting a few of the members
but um to be there joining us later i
don't know stuck in traffic or something
um okay
good morning and welcome to team
district council's virtual audience
crucially committee committee on
wednesday 26
august 2020 i'm your chair sally morgan
all participants here today are taking
part remotely
and the committee is being viewed online
and recorded so please bear this in mind
throughout the meeting
if in the event of a break in the
internet connection or a power cut
please bear with us as we try to
reconnect
if we're not able to reconnect after 15
minutes the meeting will be adjourned
and reconvened
at a later date please check the
committee page
on our website for further details
please make sure all microphones are
muted when you're not speaking to avoid
any background noise levels
please keep your points short and do not
interrupt when someone is speaking
if you wish to comment please raise your
electronic blue hand and wait to be
called
all counsellors have been sent the
agenda for today's meeting
we'll be holding a short five-minute
break after the notice of motion item
um at that point please don't leave the
meeting um
in case you can't log back on just
simply switch your mute button
on and switch off your camera um so stay
in the meeting but switch off visual and
audio
and then we can come back five minutes
later
any members of the public who want to
view the agenda can do so by visiting
our website teambridge.gov dot uk
and i'll now start the committee by
doing the roll call of committee members
when you hear your name please confirm
by saying president
uh myself sally morgan i'm here vice
chair councillor dave rollerson
present that's
i've had apologies from councillor john
pederick and thanks for stephen purser
present thank you
okay um i shall go through the agenda
items
um apologies throughout already had from
uh councillor federick
john pedreck um minutes of the previous
meeting to approve and sign the minutes
of the meeting held
19th of december that's a long time ago
um
i'm happy to propose that we approve
those do i have a second
if anybody is any is there anything
anyone would like to bring up from the
minutes
i'll second sally thank you counselor
that's great thanks steven
okay any declarations of interest
nope uh have we had any public questions
i haven't been made aware of any no we
don't we've had no public
questions okay any member questions
no no no thank you
okay in that case i'll go
straight to um the notice of motion
um i'll read out in case people haven't
got their agenda in front of them
um we considered a notice of motion on
equality of representation on
the timbre district represented by
council jeffries
the notice of motion uh was resolved and
agreed it would be referred to audit
scripting committee
overview scrutiny committee executive
with the report to go back to full
council
um the audit scripting committee are
asked to consider the following points
um it was it was a a large
notice of motion and we have got three
of those points for us to consider on
our committee
um review of governance of the council
which will comprise
one a review of the council's own hr and
equalities practices
including provision for member and
officer training
two the council setting up an advisory
board
consider um bame within the context of
covid and a review for the council
community fund
criteria to promote projects which
address inequalities
and raising educational attainment
within underrepresented groups
thought we'd just have councilman join
us
um a recommendation was circulated
yesterday um it took a while for us to
get
the wording right so that's why it
didn't come out straight away
we've got a proposed recommendation for
this item
and the recommendation is that one a
board of representatives
from locally formerly constituted groups
representing those with protected
characteristics
as defined by the equality act be formed
to review the council equality impact
assessment on the covert recovery plan
once this is completed
and two a spotlight review group
comprising of the chair of audit
scrutiny council jefferies as the mover
of the notice of motion
counselor malone councillor linda
pedrick
and council thorne
we decided on these members because
obviously um
councilwoman pedrock has already linda
pedro has already started a great deal
of work on um
hr and equalities uh and i think her
skills would be
um very much appreciated in this group
and also the makeup of the group it
comprises of every
council group represented so we've got
independent members conservative members
a mutant says no member
and a lib dem member plus the chair of
audit scrutiny
so but the whole of the council is
represented in that in that small group
um and this review group um
will review the council's hr and
equalities practice including the
provision of
equalities training for members and
officers
and b review the criteria for the
council's community fund and recommended
the recommendations be made to ensure
funding promotes projects which address
inequalities and c consider who should
be invited to join the board of
representatives as detailed in
recommendation one above
um there's quite a lot of work
there which obviously we can't we
haven't got time to do
today and we haven't got the resources
to do today which is why
um the recommendation is the review
review group takes this on
um and what i would like us to do
as members today in a moment i'm going
to propose the recommendation
and what i would like us to do as
members today
is to consider those three strands that
audit has been tasked with scrutinizing
and looking at
and rather than have a general
discussion which we had
at full council which was very useful
that we focus our um discussion and
debate today
on those three strands and um
but members of this committee and
and also from wider council come forward
with
um proposals pragmatic ideas that
the review group can take forward and
work on recommendations for
uh the review group's final
recommendations will come eventually to
the executive
so all members will have the opportunity
to see those recommendations and to
comment on them when they come
come to uh the executive but in the
meantime today
um what would be very useful is if
members
could focus their ideas and their debate
on helping the review group and giving
us material giving us
ideas giving us um pragmatic solutions
that we can put into our recommendations
um so i i hope um
members understand what i mean if you
need me to be more clear
let me know but we've had a very wide
and general
debate uh and this is really about
making sure we get the job done and get
it get the job done properly and
utilizing your skills and your ideas to
make sure that we do that
um so can i can i throw that then open
to anybody who um would like to make
comments
um or um you know come forward with an
idea
i've come forward with some um
information i know council jeffries
has sent me a great deal of information
which would be very useful
for when we come to work on the review
group but you know we've got a broad
spread of councillors here
today um and i think your opinions
need to be considered very much so um
when we come to look at the um when we
review group gets together
councillor
thank you chair um yes i mean i'm i'm
more than happy to to set them the
recommendations i think
uh they're very i was concerned uh
initially that we were going to debate
all the elements of the motion which i
thought was
probably a bit too much for audit but
i'm glad to see that this little group
of three are very specific
to sort of the remit of the audit
committee and where we are
um certainly i think i mean i would
almost think
probably annual compulsory training
should be
included in there for uh all councillors
in terms of uh black and minority ethnic
and and also some training i mean i i
must admit when i saw
eia um i i briefly had to look it up to
realize it was an
equality impact assessment and quite
what that involved and i guess
other members might might appreciate
some training around
or some information around what's
involved in the quality impact
assessment although
i think the group that's been set up is
is that something obviously that they
can investigate
and if further information is required
to members that that can come from that
group
um also i i mean
i used to sit on the um well no sorry
that's
really that the community uh members
fund
um i'm not sure whether the criteria
were last looked at but certainly again
i think it'd be useful just to to go
through that criteria and refresh
everybody's memories as to what's
available
um although of course sadly you know
with the times we're in the money
available is a bit less than it was
before but nevertheless
that that money that we've got should be
well focused uh
especially as it's a smaller amount so
so yes chair
i'm happy to to recommend the second
rather
thank you thanks to the person that's
much appreciated so i propose new
um we will accept that um uh
recommendation
but obviously in the meantime we want as
many um as much
uh as many contributions as possible
from from other members that are here
today that
will help the uh spotlight regroup do
the work
um thanks for rolling david
thank you chair uh i agree with the
comments that
uh councillor persona made and i think
my good ones
i just wanted looking for ideas if the
spotlight review group
when looking at um hr policies and so on
is
look around the country to other
councils and large organizations for
example is a good practice
and mythology as to how they would have
carried out such a review in the past
because i think
there must be some learning out there
and again back onto the uh councillors
community fund
possibly to ask the community
through adverts and social media they
have any ideas of what
could be done with that money i mean
there may be no particular group set up
at the moment but
possibly people could get together with
and produce projects that would promote
the objectives of the motion so that's
my initial thoughts
thank you chairman thank you um council
jeffries
hi thank you um i just want to say thank
you for everybody's hard work i really
um like what i've heard in terms of how
things have been taken forward and the
small chunks that have been taken by
all of it screwed me
breaking up a bit nina
sorry nina you're breaking up a bit it's
a it's a bad line from portugal
um
[Music]
i'm happy to be involved as much as
possible obviously i will be involved
leave the tree
is it really bad
can you hear me better not you you're
fading in and out a little bit to be
honest okay well it wasn't a huge amount
of stuff that i was going to say so i'll
just leave it
there but it was just to thank everybody
for their hard work so far
okay thank you well thank you for the
notice of motion i think it's given
everybody um
a lot a lot to think about so um thank
you
and thank you for obviously you're going
to be on the spotlight
as well
i can't see any more hands up is anybody
else like to make um
a comment or or or add something that
the review group can use and take
forward
it would be very very useful if you
could
uh there was a lot um to be said at full
council
by a lot of people um
but i can't see any more comments today
i see you've joined us
obviously you're going to be taking some
of the items that overview and screw to
me
um yeah you and i work together to make
sure that we cover all aspects and make
sure
dovetails we'll make sure we do that
absolutely
thank you okay um
okay oh that's the conclusion
sorry sorry
you need to unmute mary
thank you that's it perfect i agree with
the
all that's been said up to now we're
talking about
councils here of course the staff have
to uh
go along with all this and and i i feel
that in
it i was personnel chairman at one time
and i always feel that the staff have
always taken into account
uh this issue and uh i'd like to think
that
you know the staffing side of this is
considered as well as the councillor
side
uh and uh i do think they're doing a
good job but i think
they all it needs to be taken into
account with everything else
wrapped into the uh whole discussion
it's it's a whole a whole council
approach you mean yeah
yes thank you thank you yeah um pedreck
thank you chair um just to reassure you
mary
before covered um i was the diversity
and equality champion and i was working
with
rachel from hr he was very keen
to put together some training packages
on equality and hate
and diversity so this would tie in
with that and i would strongly recommend
that we include rachel
on the group if we could because her
knowledge is invaluable
that's it really thank you thank you
we've we've um
got a number of officers lined up with
specific skills
that will help us with the group um and
i i'm personally i'm really looking
forward to it
i remain as chair um
we also got a councillor again
yeah thank you again chair just you
mentioned the full council and
a lot of the discussion was was about
the full support and the reasons
it's vital to to support this motion and
ensure that it's
implemented so just to reiterate that at
this committee this is vital work
absolutely necessary and and really has
to be pursued with energy and vigor
so just just to add that emphasis that
we've kind of been through the process
of accepting it and
now we're into the the process perhaps
of implementation but it's worth saying
why it's so
important and it absolutely is and
maybe strain off the brief just a little
bit the motion contains a lot about
working with education and maybe
schools and devon county council the the
proposals we have here about the border
representatives and
spotlight group could equally be applied
i think
to those who looking at the educational
aspects of
this motion i think it's probably a good
approach
perhaps also with involving educational
establishments whether we could make
that recommendation from here
or that's going too far from our brief i
don't know anyway thank you chairman
um yeah thank you obviously i mean what
i i was um
hoping as well is is people would help
us consider um
you know we've got to set up an advisory
board and that's going to be
um the the task um
of the spotlight review group to
consider who should be invited
and and who should we invite you know
that that's that's um an issue um
for example there's a group
in team bridge the travelling um gypsy
group in in team bridge
you know i i think it's possibly a good
idea to
invite them as as they are pretty much
an underrepresented
group um particularly within government
and local government
so um there are a number of um
people who we should consider to um
invite to join the board of
representatives
um and i was i was hoping we might get
some ideas from you today as to who we
should potentially
consider um you might not have
thoughts on that today but you know
obviously message message any of us on
the group
um with your thoughts and ideas i mean i
realized you know
some of you didn't hear the uh proposed
recommendation until
late yesterday or early this morning so
maybe you haven't had time to
think about it um so you know please
please
message um members of the spotlight
group with your ideas and thoughts on
this because
you know it needs to come from the whole
council uh and then it will go back to
the whole council pretty much to be
approved so you know let's make this a
joint thing
sorry
thank you chair there is a a youth
coastal youth group i think it's called
and that's
that contains a lot of um youth
organizations throughout timbridge
so that would be a good a good group to
have on
the board and also if we're going down
the education
route and there's a
organization called um dualish action
for youth and similar organizations
around
maybe one of their trustees something
like that says we've got a full
remit of people thank you
another group that i considered is a
representative from the
bengali association um
because there's there's no
representation of a local government
from the bengali community of which
they're quite a large community within
devon and within team
um and obviously they
potentially our expert may may
experience some
um unpleasantness from from
some elements of the public so it'd be
interesting to have them as
members of the group i do have a couple
of contacts um on that group so that's
one people
consider consider asking um
stephen
thank you chad yeah yeah councillor
pedrick and yourself have really
sort of picked up the point i was making
is actually i mean
some of the spotlights work we'll be
actually identifying
all these groups and between the pair of
you you've mentioned a couple
um i think there's devin youth as well
there's a whole
vast range of organizations out there
that we perhaps don't know about at all
and and would be useful to be contacted
and
or involved in the spotlight group quite
how we find them all i don't know
whether it's
like yourselves you we drew up a list of
who we know of and that's fed into the
group but
yes i think some research on on what
groups are out there
and i suspect that some hidden groups as
well that none of us know about that
are currently under represented the the
representation as well
thank you thank you i've seen two more
hands i'm not sure what order they came
up in but i'm going to go with council
jeffrey's first
thank you um i was just thinking about
the different groups that are around but
i think it might be
useful um because we're looking at
underrepresented people i used to work
in recovery services
who have a wider range of people that
they also connect to
and so it might be worth speaking to
some of our contacts there to see if
anybody might like to be involved
um and um
what used to be connections but i can't
remember the name they've changed their
name haven't they now
but i think they they would also be
useful because they do a lot of work
with young people
and also across devon so yeah
yeah thank you thank you it's a good
list
um thank you if you're looking for uh
people to give advice there's a devon
county council used to work with an
organization called hickmap based in
sidwell street in exeter
uh and they have um a number of
services and clubs and social events and
support groups for
people from a whole variety of uh ethnic
backgrounds
in exeter like they've there's a contact
person in den county council that
may be able to help us to trace them but
they got a huge
uh amount of experience working um
in this air in this area um
i can give you the just as a name anyway
hikmat through devon county council yeah
thank you well i'm hoping that people
will um
if you if you send us emails of um
who you think should be involved or
contacts that you've got ideas that we
can approach
um
got your hand up could you um to add
something
okay i've just had a couple attacks from
a number of people that can't get on
um cancer due has you to join us but i
think he's watching us
um online instead um i can't see any
more
blue hands i thought this i thought this
debate might be a bit longer
we might have quite a few more
contributors sally just
as you're talking about people who can't
get on yeah um
counselor parker khan is in hospital
with her husband at the moment and
she wanted to be here so she sends her
apologies
so she can't join although she wanted to
well
send her our best wishes please it's
husband was in hospital
so i'll send that thank you yeah okay
thank you thank you very much
okay um okay so we've got no more
comments no more um councillors have got
their hands up
um so
are members of the committee happy
to uh accept the recommendations sally
just just want just one more thought you
might be worth
writing out to town council and parishes
they might have some
um ideas of people that they think
should be involved
yeah yeah well there was one one
um group that i thought would be
interesting if you know
um something that would would be
relevant
is there are lots of local history
groups
um that might have something to add um
you know when we've been talking about
place names and this would add to the
education side
of the notice of motion um there's a lot
of history in some of the place names
that
we're ignoring and we don't know and a
lot of the history groups might have
some
very useful information um that we can
use and and
make sure that people are aware of so
and and not obviously parish and town
capsules
are of the contacts for a lot of those
history groups um
so yeah thank you that's that's a that's
a good point we'll make sure we do that
with them okay
i can see no more hands um
so i propose that we accept
the recommendation for um agenda item
sixth
notice of motion i've had a second from
councillor persa
um committee members um
[Music]
can i just do a quick roll call and
check that you're in favor
or against or i'm staying is that okay
um okay so if you are in favor of um
[Music]
the recommendation um councillor morgan
sorry can i just confirm um you
mentioned about members of the committee
um emailing um who they think we could
contact
yeah um we just with the internet and
everything we haven't um some of
the names that we're not familiar with
we might not have picked up um because
i might not have picked up the proper
the full name so if members
if we could build that could we build
that into the recommendation for
members of the committee to email yes
they think we can contact just to
confirm that we get the correct
um names on on those um those
organizations thank you
yes yeah yeah i mean obviously um i mean
the recommendation would be that you
know if counselors have got something to
contribute all welcome
um so yes yes that's fine
if you email myself as chair i think
and democratic services i think that's
probably the best way to do it
and then we make sure that that gets on
onto the agenda for the working group
if people are happy with that okay
so we've got a recommendation that's
been proposed and saturn did
can i just go around to uh each um
member please counselor olson
i'm sorry you muted and then spoke david
you're on you're not on mute at the
moment peter is an e4
you're
but
[Music]
um it looks like councillor rollerson's
microphone wasn't working then
he keeps turning off the talk yeah right
can you hear me
yes we can hear you now yes
yeah please yes yeah yeah
yeah yeah okay well thank you thank you
i vote
right but we got that yes i apologize
very much
excellent cox four
that's the mary cole club oh thank you
that's lee malone
didn't hear you liam sorry you're muted
uh four thank you thank you thanks for
bill thorne
thank you bill um that's my person
obviously you secretly
thank you that's carriage um
obviously we need to convene a meeting
of the
um review group as soon as possible
we'll sort that out after after this
meeting
um uh that's great
thank you very much now said we were
going to have a five-minute
break um which gives
the opportunity for members not on the
committee to leave us if they wish to or
they're welcome to state the rest of the
committee
we've got um a
quite extensive agenda to get through
we've got another six items
and we are waiting for a couple of um
other officers and um our auditor to
join us so i was just gonna suggest that
maybe we have the five-minute break in a
little while because it didn't this
this debate didn't go on for as long as
i expected it two years i was expecting
it to go a little bit longer
so members who are not on the committee
are welcome to stay with us
um in the meantime we need to wait
for julie massey to join us from grant's
aunt
um
is she with us not yet
um chair we're just emailing her now to
let her know that
we're moving on to their part of the
agenda
okay thank you so if if members can just
be patient just wait a bit um
if you wish to dash the balloon for two
minutes i'm sure you've been managed
so
wow
uh
linda put your blue hand down please
thank you
actually sally i might leave the meeting
now okay
okay bye you're missing a treat
yes i'm sure i am
i've got grandson in the lounge okay
okay
thanks for joining us
hi julie you're all going to be on mute
just because
we have it set to automatic commute
hi okay
um hi julie thanks for joining us
um okay item seven on the yeah sorry can
we just check that everyone's back
sorry check that everyone's back yes
thanks
yeah okay
that's a roller son disappear for a bit
there he is
yep i'm back but i've had a lot of
problems with my uh
zoom connection just now right my
internet and wi-fi are fine but
the zoom just seemed to collapse and
i've not seen it happen before
anyone else had a problem was it me i
bought myself an ethernet cable and
attached it directly to my modem and
i've had no
well the wi-fi hasn't dropped out that
that was the worry for me
it was still good okay i'll uh watch it
carefully back with us thank you cox
there he is thank you that's a cold
cloth
i can see her it looks like her camera's
off at the moment so
she must not be back okay
[Music]
she might still be away um just
thank you
[Music]
um
welcome back mary
you're me sorry man
you're gonna meet yeah thanks man just
stretching my legs
good idea okay thank you um
welcome back um item seven
um welcome julie massey from grant
thornton
um item seven's our external audit
report
over to you chair thank you very much
indeed and um
i haven't seen any everybody for for a
while so i hope you all doing well
and i'll keep them well um just in terms
of the paper today
it's just a progress update report um
members will recall
and because of the cancellation of the
last order committee we did
um circulate uh our final audit plan
an audit plan addendum in relation to
the additional risk
around kovid 19 that we circulated to to
members so thank you
um to members for for release and
further comments back to us
on that um this paper just really just
gives you an updated position as to
where we are
and and how things are changing uh
with with the um accounting order
timetable and i'm sure um
your uh youtube finance officer will
pick up some of that as well when we
come onto the account item
later on but just in terms of where we
are with the audit now so
um the audit uh commenced this month so
so we're virtually on site uh
undertaking the
uh the the audit of the the draft
financial statements uh at the moment
and the intention then is to bring uh
our audit finance report uh back to this
committee
in on in october for then moving that on
to to full council for for sign off
uh in in in november um we've tried to
uh reflect in this progress report some
of the impact that
obviously the more virtual way of
working as far as the audit is concerned
uh and the impact of covid19 um it's
it's had a number of different
implications one in terms of the actual
preparation of the accounts themselves
but also in terms of how we've had to
conduct the audits that we've been
undertaking so far
um the first thing is in terms of the
actual accounts themselves
obviously there will be a number of
areas potentially where
um kovid19 may bring some more
uncertainties into the numbers that you
will
see within the financial statement
because um we know that that the the
impact the pandemics had lots of
different implications to the accounts
and indeed
we ran a workshop session um a virtual
uh webinar session
for um chief finance officers up and
down the country just to talk through
some of the implications of of
that for the accounts um the sorts of
areas that um
we would expect that to to it to impact
is
one potentially around property
valuations because obviously
because of the timing of when lockdown
came in
we know that it's caused some real
challenges for some uh
property valuers in terms of one being
able to undertake site inspections but
also because of the
absence of um of market
information on on on trades
around properties around that period
it's been very difficult particularly
for some commercial property out there
um to to to forms of uh reasonable
sort of valuations and so we're aware
quite a lot of
values have been put in um uh clauses
and an estimation uncertainty paragraphs
into their valuation reports which
obviously will have
implications for um for for us uh
in terms of the the the audit as well
um some of the other areas that it will
also impact is potentially around
collectibility of debts
um obviously particularly some of your
commercial debts council tax business
rates
uh we've certainly seen some impacts
around collect collectibility of
of of income um and so we'll be looking
as part of the audit
to pick up how officers have considered
that and whether there's any additional
um impairment provisions that need to be
put aside
in relation to that and also generally
anything that's subject to estimation
in your accounts um the the nature of
the pandemic may
just give rise to further uncertainties
around that as well so there's there's
likely to be areas where
additional disclosures are needed
and particularly a lot of the focus
we'll be doing around the audit this
year
is around feature financial
sustainability and that has
has two strands to it really one in
relation to the accounts
um from a go and concern perspective now
we absolutely expect your authority to
continue for the foreseeable future as
far as going concern is concerned
um you need some sort of statutory basis
to in effect
um to shut down a council but that's
that's not to say that um
some of the uh challenges around um
providing
government funding and support to um
recompense for loss of income
that's been a real challenge i know that
the government's issued its
um compensation scheme to allow um
authorities to put in claims now for for
loss of income that was announced this
week
um but that ultimately will you know
there are lots of financial challenges
that authorities have to deal with and
so we will make sure to look at as part
of both the accounts and the value for
money work
and what what your authority is doing to
to respond to some of those um
financial challenges so i mean that's
the the main bulk of the the the
progress update i think the audit so far
it's it's still very early days but so
far has been um progressing
um as as planned um as i said one of the
the major challenges has really been
trying to conduct the audit in a more
in a more virtual environment and so
whereas traditionally
you know we would be all on site we'd be
sat in the in the finance team room we'd
be able to
pop our head around the door and ask
questions as we go
um but that's not it's not quite as
straightforward as that now um
having to do a lot of the work around uh
using teams and other
online functionality to share screens uh
walkthrough
systems and things on on on screen and
that and that sort of thing so
um we'll see how things go in terms of
how things progress over over the next
few weeks
um i think naturally things will take a
little bit longer to to get through
things because that's just the reality
of the situation at the moment but
um i i believe that you know the way
that our team is working the office at
the moment is
is is is progressing is progressing well
so um
i didn't propose to say any more than
that at this stage other than
obviously what's stated in the update
the report but happy to take any
particular questions from from from
members um
thank you thank you it's at times like
this you know we're uncharted territory
but it's good that we have a good
relationship with our auditors and and
you know um you've got the relationship
we have and the officers got a
relationship with you
you know that uh you can communicate i
think the key word has got to be
uncertainty hasn't it for everything um
uh thank you i don't know if anybody
else has got anything that they wish to
add or anything they want to ask
um no
oh that's not awesome um
thank you chair just a question around
the uncertainty i mean
have you any idea how you compensate for
that or what a good response to the
uncertainty might be
i mean it seems that we're in a world
where the future is so uncertain
and you're trying to audit a good
response any any views what a
how you would come to a view what's a
good response or an adequate response
uh i know it's a hard question but i'd
be interested if you've thought about it
gosh it that that is that is a difficult
question um
everybody's circumstances a a different
counselor and certainly you know we've
been talking to different authorities
around the impact of some of this and
and how we can make the audit work as
effectively as
as we can and you know certainly for
district councils
you know your finance teams you know
it's a very small team you know some of
the larger authorities have
have a bigger finance function and and
if staff are you know redeployed to
to to to focus on other priority
um areas in response to the pandemic you
know there's more resilience and
capacity within that team
um i guess you know the government has
responded in terms of extending the
timetable and so really it's it's just
about how we
we continue to work with with martin
martin and colleagues as to
you know to manage the processes as best
as we can
um we're trying to virtualize as much as
we can i think one of the added
challenges i guess with
with with team bridges is is
historically a lot of the working papers
have been
very sort of paper-based in files and
manual based and so
trying to make more of that transition
into more of an electronic sort of
virtual kind of process um we're getting
there this
as much as we can but you know be
provided electronically uh we can but
uh you know making use of scanning
facilities and and things like things
like that
as well um so we will just have to see
how how it goes but we have to kind of
respond and tailor the way that would
work to every individual authorities
um circumstances i mean some authorities
are
have always sort of made very good use
of teams and so when we went into the
sort of pandemic
actually working more in this more
environment actually was probably more
akin to what they were traditionally
used to and so they found that
transition you know really really simple
so um it's very difficult to sort of
generalize as
this is what good looks like because we
just have to be as responsive as we can
to everybody's individual
circumstances really but it's just to
manage the com
the committee's expectations you know i
would like to sit here now and say
you know we'll come to the october
committee and everything will be done
finished etc but we don't know until we
get into the audit we start picking
samples
that may be that there's certain samples
they'll say oh well that's in a archive
box in a cupboard somewhere
in this in this room and you're not
going to be able to see that yet how
we're going to get around that some of
those things
will be easily you know worked around
but some of them it may be that
um as we get further into the pan uh
into the
the sort of the um the kind of reversal
of the the the lockdown arrangements
that
we may be able to say right okay well
you know you can come on site for
you know a day in in in late september
say and we could
we'll just run through all the documents
in what in one go we'll just have to
manage those sorts of challenges
as as we go through but we just don't
really know what to expect until
we decide and and encounter what we what
we do so
um we'll obviously keep everybody posted
as to how things um
uh how things progress and um uh
but i mean so so far as i said
everything's been been going
okay as far as i'm aware but um sorry
there's a very long answer to your your
question
counselor but at the moment it's it's
quite difficult to try and answer that
because everybody's circumstances are
slightly different i knew it's going to
be a difficult question so thanks for
the answer
and thanks for the enormous amount of
work you're doing and the finance team
as well
it must be nigh and impossible sometimes
so good work
thanks and you have every sympathy from
the committee i'm sure
thank you yeah i'll exactly that i mean
i find that student
really got their work cut out and and i
think half the battle is recognizing
that you know this is uncharted
in uncharted territory and there are
things that we just don't know
about and things we don't know are going
to happen but it's having that awareness
um being prepared that we could be you
know
center curveball at some point and being
prepared for that or being as prepared
as we can for that so
uh thank you cancel us on
thanks very much for that yeah chair and
uh thanks everyone for doing all the
work they are at the moment i was just
going to
um just ask really what would actually
happen if in fact it came to the
figures in the accounts and then
subsequently you found perhaps there was
a variation at the
31st of march or whatever it is in a
valuation or something like that
that wasn't and cropped up later through
the course of the audit
um how would you treat that in the
actual accounts do you alter the
accounts
at a later date or i know they're draft
only at the moment
but if something did crop up what is the
process for adjusting accounts
if it was presumably material or
something of that nature
yeah so it would kind of fall into sort
of two character
categories really so there's there's
things which are subject to estimates
and there's something which i would call
a post balance sheet event so i'll cover
both in in turn so
the estimate side of things is is really
about you know your officers
um have a have a certain timetable they
work to and they have to
put together those accounts based on the
best available information at that point
in time
now naturally during the normal course
events you know
by the time we come into the audit
further information might be available
to us that wasn't available to officers
at the time
they prepared those drafts so we would
undoubtedly expect estimates to change
um from from from time to time just
because of the passage of time
and and you're right counselor if if it
was a situation where
that estimate had changed by a material
amount
we we would be instructing officers at
that point in time to
update the account because um it's clear
that those
that that information provides more more
clarity
to to the situation if it was not
material we would just report that as a
as an unadjusted item
uh in in in the audit fines report that
we bring back to this committee um in
october so
that's generally the basis in which um
estimates would work so
we're not necessarily saying officers
have got it wrong it's just more
information has become available so it's
important
we give the right context that if if
that were to be the case
the second aspect is what we would call
post-balance sheet events so what
sometimes you would have circumstances
where um
new information comes to life that
actually adjusts
something that uh was in place at the
year end so a good example for that
would be say
i don't know you've got a you've got a
court you've got a court case
um that's that's in progress you didn't
you didn't know at the 31st of march
um you knew there was a case in place
but you didn't know the 31st march what
the outcome of that
would have been so you may not have put
anything in your accounts at that point
or may just have put a contingency
disclosure of a possibility
of something happening um but it's
possible that
you know three months after the year end
you get you get a court decision
that actually confirms a certain outcome
that actually says actually you should
have provided for that cost
because the circumstances were actually
related to that case were in place
before the year and you just didn't know
really any certainty about the value of
it and in those cases you would have
something called an adjusting event
which would actually then
mean that you'd have to recognize um
the the costs associated to that with
the accounts there could be some
instances where you have things that are
post balance [ __ ]
post balance sheet events which are what
we call non-adjusting so a good example
for that in relation to say that the
covered pandemic would be um obviously
lockdown came
in sort of you know middle middle of
march
lots of things were happening in march
but quite a lot of authorities have done
lots of things
subsequent to the year end to try and
address
and respond to the pandemic whether that
be um
you know close um close down certain
services
or redeploy staff in a certain way or
restructure how they do things
because those specific activities have
happened after the year
and those wouldn't be considered
adjusted they would be non-adjusting
events so there's very specific criteria
and circumstances for all the different
things so
you'd have to look at each individual
item and circumstance to determine which
one of those sort of three baskets it
would
it would fall into but there's there's
very specific accounting quality that
you need to consider along each of those
i hope that helps okay yeah thanks very
much indeed and thanks very much for the
answer as well
thanks a lot thank you um
okay does anybody else have anything
else they wish to ask
or add or no
okay um shorter than i thought it would
be as well thank you
julie no problem at all i hope you're
well anyway
thank you i'm i'm happy to stay on the
call because obviously
the items on the accounts laters i
wouldn't mind staying around for that
one if possible
that would be great thank you thank you
very much okay
thank you okay um the next item on the
agenda is the strategic and corporate
risk report i donate
um and this is for us to note this
report um
[Music]
liz over to you
yes good morning so the report today is
just providing the committee with an
overview of the current status of our
corporate and strategic risks so
in the report the background just covers
some outline detail about
the types of risk we manage at cambridge
we've got 25 strategic risks
and 12 corporate risks in addition to
that but not being reported today
are service risks and project risks
so the the second the third section of
the report
is to do with the risk management
strategy we have
this in place it is reviewed on a
regular basis
and that's every two years and it's due
for review
this year the strategic leadership team
has carried out a review
and their recommendation is that there
should be no change to the strategy
this is attached as appendix a in your
report
basically the strategy is in three main
sections
it outlines our policy in the first
section
our second section is all about
organization and that includes
areas such as responsibilities
and the third section is the arrangement
that's actually how we manage our risks
in practice
there's a couple of other sections which
list some key documents
and some risk management performance
measures
i think we've taken the view that this
is still fit for purpose
and uh at this point chair i don't know
if they're good to pause if there are
any questions on that particular item
any questions uh counselor olson
thank you chair just reading the right
report um
page 26 the budget review in the
table there you've got reporting um to
the executive on a quarterly basis
in view of the what we've just heard
about the impact of
covid and the massive uncertainties um
wouldn't that be better to do it on a
monthly basis
just to be sure the responses are swift
and timely
okay did you hear that
i did hear that uh um i think that's on
a later page of the report
is that right on the section three is
that one section
five six
dave you muted sorry
um so is this the wrong thing i'm
looking at the report
the risk assessment on strategic
corporate risk report
no yes we're on the right report i just
haven't got page numbers on my report
okay sorry about that
second page uh paragraph six
all right uh and this this is read down
there about action needed
and it was just i don't dispute the fact
it's red
it's just the reporting uh time scales
to the executive
you've got quarterly reports i wonder
whether
the executive should be updated on a
monthly basis or more regular basis
given the vast uncertainties that we're
facing
that was my question okay okay thank you
um
martin is that something you can answer
please
yeah we um we did agree to um
update the executive uh monthly so
that's what we have been doing
um in the short time scales that um
that we've had available and so there is
a report going to executive again
in september to update um i think
in terms of our general finances the
um there will then be a budget
realignment which is going to full
council
at the end of september um and then i
think the plan
after that is to come back to executive
every other month until we get to um
setting up budgets for next year so
there'll be another report then
in november and then in december we'll
be putting together the information for
the next year next year's budget process
early in january
thank you so it's the wording on the
document perhaps should be updated
thank you thanks
okay have we got any more questions on
the strategic and corporate risk report
okay the members happy to note that item
[Music]
yeah i can see people do i need to go
around yeah i can see thumbs up bill are
you happy with that
yeah okay i don't think we need to do a
role for chris
um yeah could we maybe instead of a roll
call could we just say
does anyone have any objections or would
anyone dissent or
want to um abstain from voting
if not then we can probably just okay
we're happy that it's just to note the
report anyway isn't it yes yeah these
are just
to know the report thank you thank you
very much
okay uh item nine treasury
management and landing list i believe
that's
uh
yeah it is indeed sorry i was just
unmuting myself
yeah thank you um so um
the report is to confirm that we have um
produced the draft 1920 accounts
and they've been published on our
website and we've also included as we
normally do the details on the
treasury management lending list for
members to have a look at
and also the activities that we got up
to in terms of treasury management for
1920 so
they're in the appendices so normally
the accounts come to audit scrutiny
before they come to executive
but with the impact of covid
the change in the reporting timetable
for the accounts
we felt it was important to let
executive know
before all the scrutiny occurred where
we thought we were with the 1920
out turn because that helped to inform
where we were in terms of our
reserves and funding um as part of the
process of of also identifying where we
were in terms of
the budget gap for the current financial
year so it's
um it's sort of gone the other way
around this year so normally it would be
more scrutiny than executive
but executive i've had some of this
information already but obviously we
hadn't quite
finalized the accounts at that point so
um this is the normal meeting that we
would have to discuss
the draft accounts before or during the
audit period
and and then we'll come back again with
the final set once grant thornton have
done have done their work
so um important points to note i think
from the report
um are that our closing general reserves
are 1.987 million
which is slightly higher than our
anticipated figure back in february when
we set
the probable budget
and the report gives you a link to the
accounts themselves
so they're quite a lengthy document 123
pages in all but
there is a link there and i'm happy to
answer any questions on the accounts but
there's quite a lot of detail in there
um in section two of the report we do
identify that that changed timetable um
and julie's alluded to earlier
um in a report on the grant thornton
publications
um section three the report um points
the reader of the accounts to
specific pages that um are of or of
interest particularly around the
narrative statement
and information on our property plant
and equipment
and reserves and section three
identifies some of the variations that
have occurred
during the during the financial year to
get us to the position that we are
now section four
identifies what we've done in terms of
treasury management um
our lending list and any changes that
have occurred
that's shown in appendix one and section
five is the overall detail on where
we've invested our money during the year
and the returns that we've made on those
activities
so at this stage really it's um
for members to to note that the accounts
are out there and that they're draft
um there will be audited um
and and we will be working with the
auditors on that
um i i guess i'll just sort of
add to what julie mentioned in terms of
our working papers so we've done a lot
of work this year
um to make things easier for them to
work online so we've
because we have an old financial
management system that we are looking to
change at some point in the future um
we have to work with what we've got um
and we have
scanned in a huge amount of
documentation
to allow them to verify a lot of that
work online we've created a lot more
electronic documents
that were previously um manual documents
so
i'm hopeful that the information that
we've got in terms of working papers
meets their requirements and if there
are the gaps you know
maybe we can meet in the office in
september to discuss those bits and
pieces so
i think that in that respect the audit
should go smoothly
but yeah happy for any questions on on
the accounts or the
treasury activities we've done thank you
thank you martin
um have you got any questions for morgan
phil you need to milk bill
[Laughter]
i'll get used to it one day um
mark i'm through the chair uh martin i
was just looking at the lending list
i've got appendix one on page 47 there
about the
ccla property and diversified income
funds and things where it's authorized
to invest in these is this something
that
um after what uh our auditors
said about the property market and that
is it is
is this still going for do you use them
at the moment or is it
something that's available if you should
feel it necessary at some stage
yeah so it's been kept on there as
something that's available
um at the moment we only use them to
they have a deposit account we just use
a deposit account that they have
but in terms of the property investment
fund we're not using that one at the
moment
and with um
or the impacts of covid the property
fund was suspended
for a period of time so at the moment
we're not using that
actively could i
could i just also also ask that what
would you see is a
you know with the pension fund which has
such a critical
effect on the accounts and that can you
see that culvert's going to have a
i agree with the markets seem to be
coming back
up through again but what would you
estimate as the
have you got any ideas about what what
could happen over the course of the next
year or anything like that at the moment
with the pension fund is it
uh looking particularly dire at the
moment or not
um so just a couple of things on the
pension fund so
ordinarily when we produce the year-end
accounts
we go with month 11 asset values so
the the valuations of the pension fund
at that point are then projected on to
month 12
but bearing in mind that we knew what
happened in march
and the stock market crashed we moved to
month 12
valuations so i'm fairly confident that
the the values that we've got
that have come through from our
prevention pension provider will have
given us
the right valuations at that point
because in terms of our balance sheet
it's the values at that particular point
um
there will be a huge uncertainty um
after that um and we'll work with the
auditors
around what that means um if i knew the
answers then i'd be investing in the
stock market now because
it's really difficult to know what's
going to happen and
and where it's going to go but like you
mentioned yes it dipped down
um but it has bounced back to a certain
extent
i guess it just depends what happens
globally because you know our pension
fund are invested in all sorts of
companies and chairs that you know work
across the world so it's a
it's a global issue really rather than
just a domestic one
um so yes it's a case of monitoring
where those stock markets go i think
okay and that will be reflected in in
whatever happens this year in terms of
our
balance sheet valuations okay thanks
very much
okay um stephen you've got a question
thank you really just to congratulate uh
martin and his team
uh and the auditors for for all they've
done and have been doing
i think the accounts 127 pages or
something this show which seems to
seem to add a few more pages each year
and the work they've done sort of
is is bizarrely almost sort of as normal
up to the the end of last year because
um and it belies the fact
what was going on around you while you
were trying to do a sort of a normal set
of accounts which in normal
circumstances
show a very good and healthy position
for the authority
um as you're saying has been said is is
is what comes
now this year and and the future years
is the real issues and the real risks to
us
so so really just just to to thank
martin for
and his team for carrying on in in
unprecedented circumstances
thank you thank you okay do we have any
other comments julie
yeah thank you just just to follow on um
from
from martin's comments ready it's just
just for for members to be aware of what
they're likely to see
um uh certainly in the report that we
will give
um uh in in in october um i'm for
fortunately i'm i'm also the engagement
lead for for um
for devon pension fund so i can give
some context for this from the other
side
um i certainly can't predict for the
future as to what will happen to the
markets if i could i'm clearly in the
wrong job but certainly what i can tell
you
is is where we think the direction of
travel is likely to go as far as the
audit is concerned
um we know that devon pension fund has
got a
considerable amount of pooled property
funds that it holds as part of its full
portfolio i think it's somewhere in the
region of about
uh 350 350 million for the fund as a
whole
so of which this council will obviously
have a share of that in the context of
its
its share of assets um and what what is
likely to
to to happen um from from what we've
seen happen
from some of the early pension funds
that we've started doing our audit work
on
is that they will probably need to be um
some uh
additional reference in the audit
opinion this is not a qualification or a
modification of the opinion
it's what we refer to as an emphasis of
matter and what that's trying to
do is draw attention to the readers of
the audio opinion about something that
we want to
draw your attention to in in the account
of the authority
um and what that's trying to recognize
is as i was saying earlier about
um your own property that the council
owns so team bridge council's own
property your value as part of his
valuation report would have issued
a a disclaimer
specifically identifying this material
estimation uncertainty in his valuations
that equally applies as far as the
pension fund is concerned so for the
property that's held
at a pension fund level those property
funds that those investment managers
invest in because of the stall of trade
in
um quite a lot of the investment
managers themselves have also been
issuing these
uncertainty disclosures in their
valuation reports
to to the funds and to the auditors and
so what it's likely
um that your order opinion will refer to
is this emphasis of
mata both on your own property but also
indirectly any property held
at the pension fund level in relation to
your specific share because i think in
both instances those will be of a
material
value but i think it's really important
to emphasize to the committee
that's not a qualification your opinion
what in effect will do is it will make
reference to the specific note in your
accounts where those
material uncertainties are highlighted i
just thought that'd be helpful
context just to um just for everybody to
to understand what
what might be discussed in october thank
you
thank you that's useful um
okay have we got any more
comments on that please nope
fine are members happy to note that
report
uh yes
let's see chrissy help me with that
the recommendation is on page 41. 41
just so that you're all aware
um as long as there's no dissenters or
people wishing to abstain that's fine
okay
thank you
thank you chair and good morning
everybody um
yes this is on page 53 in your agenda
um item 10. um the report before you
today is our annual report
um as members know the council is
required to have a
statutory internal audit service and at
the end of the year
the audit manager must given this annual
report
if i take you through page by page
section 2 outlines the factors that we
take into account when
drawing an opinion um we obviously
take account of the audits we've done
and the audits undertaken were in line
with the plan that was approved by
members in the previous year
um we also consider how well the
findings were accepted by management
whether there's been any significant
changes in systems
um any limitations whether we were
prevented from
um undertaking any audits which i'm
pleased to say we weren't um
there's also a section on quality of the
internal
internal audit work and performance and
we consider where we can rely on other
sources of assurance as well
um we're also involved in other
corporate working groups i'm a member of
the corporate management team
so obviously insight is gleaned from
these
different involvement in groups every
audit that we do
we give an assurance rating too and
that's outlined in
paragraph 2.3 excellent good fair or
poor
and then in 2.4 um you can see a table
there that shows that 18 of the
20 planned audits are undertaken
findings were positive generally um so
we're pleased to say that we reported
with that we completed that ninety
percent of the planned work
um a couple of audits didn't take place
the payroll audit was postponed
due to the implementation of the new
itunes system
and the risk register testing has also
been carried forward
one audit is substantially complete but
we just need to finish that one off
again that's been carried forward to
this year we also
undertake follow-up checks so if there's
been any high risk
recommendations from previous audits
we'll go back and do a check to make
sure that those have been implemented
and the findings were good on those
um ic2 ict assurance
obviously ict team which is provided by
the company strata
um and we work closely with devon audit
partnership who have kindly
asked us to include their
or audit appearance audit opinion on the
it
service and that is also giving
substantial assurance on the adequacy of
strata's control framework
we take an overview of counter fraud
arrangements i'm the key contact for the
national fraud initiative
um a fraud risk analysis is maintained
for all council services
and we have a program of quality
insurance assurance to make sure the
audits are
undertaken to the approved quality which
is defined by the public sector audit
standards
we also um ask for feedback on the
conclusion of each audit
and and that has been good um
we've completed as i said 100 of the
core systems work
and 90 of all other planned audits
um so that leads us on to the final
opinion
um is that there's generally an
effective
um control environment across the
council um
with no concerns and i'm happy to take
any questions
thank you thank you sir um
let me defeat considering the current
situation any questions
stephen
sorry yeah sorry i'm on that yeah thank
you for that
i i suppose my one question would be
about where
um the risk register um audit now sits
obviously with
with all that's going on i guess as
councillors we we
want to be really assured that the risk
register is is robust
um and i just wondered where where
where or when you'll be doing that order
yes um yes that's a very good point
stephen um i mean we
do work closely with liz um on strategic
and corporate risks
um and liaise with her but that
audit that we undertake would
traditionally test some of the
mitigations
so so it is an important one to do um
the current year resource um has been
basically firefighting covid to date
so i have to say there's no prospect of
it being done immediately
um we've been targeting all the grant
work for the business
grants and the discretionary grants and
and the welfare fund
so we're currently um looking at those
at the moment
to make sure that they're um going to
only the people they're intended to
um and we've we've spent quite a bit of
time um giving insurance in that area
and doing some
detailed testing indeed one of the
members of the team was
actually seconded to business rates in
the beginning to actually help the team
get the grants out so
um so there's no prospects of it being
done immediately
but we can certainly factor when normal
service resumes
um and i'm hoping to bring a plan to the
september
sorry the october committee um giving
that it is a
quite a unique year this year i'll
certainly prioritize
the the risk um mitigation testing
thank you thank you for that thank you
we've got any additional questions
or people wishing to abstain
um next item is the annual governance
statement
okay thank you that's me again i'm
afraid
so this is page 61 in your agenda um
annual governance statements are
effectively an mot of the council's
arrangements for risk management and
governance
they again are statutory requirements
they're published with the annual
accounts
and they have to be approved by
council so we're asking the committee
today to recommend the draft annual
governance statement that's before you
to full council for approval and subject
to you being happy with it
and the report just sets out the steps
that are taken to
um compile the ags it basically follows
a review of governance
taking into account um a review against
the sit for solis framework which
outlines the components of good
governance um
the results of our audit so the audit
opinion that you've just received the
external audit feedback
um can certainly help inform your view
when looking at the annual governance
statements
and reports from any other review
functions
we look at ombudsman's complaints
general complaints
we look at contingent liabilities in the
accounts as well just in case they've
been caused by any or legal cases to
ascertain whether these were generated
by governance weaknesses and i'm pleased
to say that there are none
um we look at the key systems and
processes that
exist to regulate the um council's
activities
and for a good overview of what a
governance framework looks like
and there's a diagram provided on 73
that shows all the various components of
governance
and how they all interact together
another key source of insurance is the
statements
each senior manager of the council
completes a detailed statement
saying that they're happy that they've
understood their managerial
responsibilities and put procedures in
place
to ensure that their services objectives
were achieved and
legal requirements were met etc
ags's must reflect the arrangements in
place
for the 2019 year so they run alongside
the accounts but they also must be
current up until the date they're
published
so we've put quite a detailed section in
this year about
covid and how we responded to that and
how that changed governance arrangements
for example
virtual meetings um and that's very
important that it remains current
and could still be um altered you know
if anything significant change between
now and and publication date
um it's been reviewed by this strategic
leadership team in july
um so the draft ags is attached on page
65
um and members are asked to recommend it
to council for approval
and again happy to take any questions
thanks
thank you yeah i mean i was going to say
this is this is something that we do
every year but obviously
um we've now got the additional um
insert of kobe 19 and like i said before
this is something we're learning
as we go along so obviously this is one
section that will
no doubt be edited added to whatever
in the foreseeable future so it's
something that we as an audit scrutiny
committee need to keep a close eye on i
think as well
um in order to make sure that
you know things are running smoothly and
obviously this
report is um for us to uh resolve to
send
to um is it full council
is it full council yeah we send this to
court council so uh it will be
scrutinized again at full council
um sorry in the meantime bill you have
something to add
thanks very much karen yes i was just um
looking through
and jumped to the end last uh last bit
to
to comment on page 71
the 2018 19 identified areas um i
wondered whether sue could give a little
bit of
information about that because it looks
like perhaps
some bits haven't been done does it look
that way or is that my
misinterpretation of it right okay
um i think that the financial
sustainability issue is
is obviously ongoing that will be a
feature each year and
you know adapted to meet the current
circumstances
um the constitution review um
i if you don't mind i will check with
the monitoring officer and and
and get back to you after the meeting on
that as i understand it the
decision-making process and the scheme
of delegation have been reviewed and
updated
and i believe there may be an item on
the agenda for council um
very shortly sort of taking that forward
but i'll i'll check in and give you a
detailed update on that after the
meeting if that's okay
and the contract rules um yes that
review has not been completed
um that's in the hands of the
procurement officer
and due to other priorities and and
obviously covid
um but it's in her work plan um for 2020
so yes that hasn't been undertaken um
it's i wouldn't say it presents a huge
risk i think it was a case of sort of
updating it in in line with latest
legislation
um and just the fact that it hadn't been
reviewed for
a few years so um that will be in the
work plan for 2020.
um so yes that that particular issue has
not
been carried out yeah all i was
interested in is actually that we put
because it hasn't been done in july so i
suppose we'll change the date and i'm
talking about sorry yes oh
yes on the constitution review that you
just need to
i know it's on the draft and that's on
on the internet at the moment isn't it
right dates there so i just have to look
at the dates when necessary that's the
thing
right that yes that's a good point i'll
amend that date to reflect it
what it actually is i think this was
drafted pre-july so
yes okay thank you bill okay thanks a
lot
hey thank you
okay so the committee uh the
recommendation here is the committee
recommends to cancel that the annual
government statement is approved this
will go to full council so it will be
scrutinized again at the
council um uh is the committee happy to
do so
yep as long as there's no
dissenters or abstainers that's fine
sure thank you thank you for that
um hey final item on the agenda
um financial instructions and contract
procedures rules
the waiver report this is for us to note
uh there is something i've noted and
i've put a bit of a question on one of
them
so you want to do you want to introduce
yourself yes yeah
thank you um so yes the financial
instructions and contract rules
recognize that in everyday life there
will be emergencies
there will be times when for legitimate
reasons it's not possible to follow the
rules
so we have a procedure for that called
the waiver procedure
and it involves the officer and their
manager putting the proposal forward
it's scrutinized by audit and the
procurement officer
and there are various level of
authorizations depending on the amounts
for example over 50 000 in spending has
to go to the
leader for approval and the managing
director
so there seems to be a lot of waivers on
this report
and i would just like to add that that's
because we haven't had a meeting since
december so this
these waivers go all the way back to
december so um although it seems a lot
um it is about average um to what we'd
normally expect to receive
um so the details of the waivers are
provided
um and again i'm happy to take any
questions
um if there are any thank you
i mean i i have a good look at all of
them and there's just one that stood out
to me which is the very last one which
was some very expensive gates and
macbook
sign notes and just wanted to explain
why they cost so much
right okay i've had a look at the waiver
form
itself and it's
for the provision i suppose the
description in our report doesn't do it
justice this is just a little tracy of
the
actual situation and it was for 12 gates
six entrance boards and to
fit and install those um so then the 9
000 and it and they they specified for
it to be in hardwood so that it was
longer lasting and less maintenance
so i suppose value for money is
something we're always very keen to
achieve
um and they'd had tried and tested
service from
this particular supplier at the dawlish
site
um so so given the quantity of
workmanship involved
um i suppose 12 gates um what's that
about
seven entrance balls that's yeah
probably about 500 pound a piece
it's um installed and fitted it
it's probably it it's probably not as
bad as it it seems on the surface
um that that level of detail would have
been a bit more useful because i saw
that 9 000 pounds for some gates and
i might thought well i could not run up
myself for effect for that
um no thank you that's helpful that
that seemed a lot more
does anybody else have any more
questions about this item
bill oh thanks very much yes it's just
the last one
really about the street marshalls don't
it tim
i was just trying to understand what
that one meant um
the street marshals are being paid for
by the office of the
police and crime commissioners i
understand from a half
million pound budget that um did we
advance the money do we expect some
money back
from them is that how it reads there or
is it um
yes i believe they've provided the
funding for the marshals
and they just needed somebody to put
them in place
um so tim i think timothy town council
were
possibly involved at the outset um but
the um the dartmoor community safety
partnership
um which which we um provide
um it was deemed that was probably the
best vehicle to sort of deliver them
through
um so rebecca hewitt
has done the procurement side of things
and
put the procedures in place to to get
the marshals up and running and
operational i think it was in a very
short time scale as well
so it's fully funded by the police and
crime commissioner
um we're just a conduit for
i suppose channeling the money and
putting it in to actually
get getting them out on the street um so
yes the money is going through our
accounts but it's it's police and crime
commissioner funding
okay thanks very much indeed for that i
should add as well for all the
environment agency
um related waivers um
ruth adams um waivers they're all fully
funded by the southwest
coastal monitoring program and funded by
the environment
agency um so um
yeah none of those are direct funded by
team bridge
but we're an agency in that respect
okay okay okay we've for the street
marshall i mean
probably debate for another day but look
you know let's see if it's not at the
expense of our pcso's who know our
communities and uh
this is trying to be done do i say it
cheaply
um but anyway i think that's a debate
for another day and uh it's coming up
police and crime commissioner's budget
um and i believe dartmoor are getting
several marshals as well so anyway thank
you
um okay does anybody have any more
questions uh
okay is there anything else anyone would
like to add before we close the meeting
uh can we just make sure that there's no
dissenters or
or abstainers again please okay people
have to note that report
yep thank you did you know that
okay is there anything else anybody
would like to add
bill you've got your hand up again
that's lovely from last time um i i
would just like to say thank you to
everybody i mean this is you know like i
said before in childhood territory
um and i think the financial team in
particular considering the uncertainty
that we're all facing
um you know i
i don't know how you you're doing it
it's it's
um thank you very much well done and um
uh you know what more can i say it's
it's a very very difficult time and i
think
as a council i think um
may be biased but i think actually we're
doing quite well in comparison to a lot
of councils we've got good
communications between us all
um we've got good communications with
external bodies in our auditors um
and long may that continue um
so at that point i'd like to say
thank you very very much and thank you
for anybody else who joined us and thank
you for
non-committee members who joined us as
well um
and thank you goodbye
thanks everybody thank you bye
bye everybody
thanks for invite sally you're welcome
you're welcome anytime
you